[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des dizaines de milliers de parisiens
haletant à 6,7 à longchamp au départ du
grand prix de l'arc de triomphe sous les
sabots du vainqueur il y à 200 millions
nous n'en sommes pas encore là tous les
chevaux ont une chance le poulain de sa
winston churchill à la hâte en le mors
aux dents dès les premières foulées
c'est très crade mais un peu
présomptueux pour l'anecdote on voudrait
bien qu'il gagne cependant c'est compter
sans me lever tôt le fils à papa
ap ap le crack italien ribot a déjà
gagné deux fois le prix de l'arc de
triomphe alors pourquoi pas moi dix mots
le vélo et joignant le geste à la parole
maul vdo prouve s'il en était besoin que
bon sang ne saurait mentir
à
comme papa il a triomphé de tous les
cracks européen avec une parfaite
maîtrise
[Musique]
cette année le salon de l'auto a ouvert
ses portes sur l'horaire car on y
viendra rêver de la voiture la plus
chère 40 millions
[Musique]
de la meilleure marché
de la plus rapide
de la voiture des voix
ou simplement de la voiture de grand
luxe et puis on regardera de plus près
les voitures pour lesquelles finalement
on n'est plus celle dont on appréciera
la réalité quotidienne
chez part on retrouvera par le jeu du
tournoi brèche les 2 pl 17 la berline et
le cabriolet tic
avec roger rivière qui songe à remplacer
les courses cyclistes par les courses
automobiles on y appréciera la ceinture
de sécurité qui peut être adaptée
et le siège inclinable jusqu'à la
position couchette qui est la
caractéristique principale de
l'équipement relaxe maximum rechercher
cette année
vedette du complexe industriel simca
dont elle est la dernière née la simca
1000 cinq chevaux nerveuse confortable
et spacieuse ne fera pourtant pas oublié
la robuste étoiles six chevaux
[Musique]
ni l'as monaco une voiture à toit
véritablement ouvrant elle ne faut pas
oublier non plus et autres aînés
l'étoile super ou la confortable
routière que s'est révélé être l'ariane
sept chevaux
[Musique]
chez peugeot on retrouvera la gamme des
404 et des 403 à moteur essence ou
diesel cette gamme s'est enrichie cette
année d'un nouveau modèle ou plutôt d'un
modèle de luxe le moteur à injection
indirecte qui développe 85 chevaux
équipe cette nouvelle venue le cabriolet
400 cap c'est là une innovation dans la
construction française
[Musique]
le salon 61 un des meilleur de l'après
guerre
la rupture entre damas et le caire est
aujourd'hui consommé dans les rues de la
capitale syrienne la foule a applaudi au
coup de force qui a mis fin à l'union
scellée en 58 avec l'egypte et qui fut
provoquée par la volte face du colonel
serrage ancien vice-président de la ra
[Musique]
quant à l'armée syrienne dont le nouveau
commandant en chef le général zahreddine
s'est fait le porte parole elle a laissé
à monsieur pouces baril le soin de
former un gouvernement civil
et tandis que les tanks montait encore
la garde dans certains quartiers de
damas c'est l exode général des
égyptiens vers le liban
[Musique]
à
fonctionnaire aux militaires ils sont
aujourd'hui indésirable en syrie
[Musique]
mais il n'avait pas oublié dans leurs
bagages le portrait du colonel nasser
[Applaudissements]
atmosphère de fête à yaoundé pour les
cérémonies de la réunification
monsieur amadou ahidjo président de la
république camerounaise qui devient
président fédéral a assisté au défilé
qui a marqué l'aboutissement du voeu
émis par le cameroun méridional
précédemment sous mandat britannique
d'être rattachée à la république
camerounaise à laquelle la france avait
accordé l'indépendance en 1960
[Musique]
après la revue militaire un défilé
résumant les activités économiques
sociales et sportives d'une nouvelle
étape se déroulait au milieu de
l'allégresse générale
[Musique]
la première phase des contacts est ouest
sur berlin s'est achevée par la visite
que monsieur grand mikko a fait au
président kennedy visite intéressante
dit on à washington
utile dit on à moscou ce qui ne veut pas
dire qu'un pas important était fait
[Musique]
à pékin la chine populaire a célébré son
douzième anniversaire
célébration maintenant classique qui
fait défiler sur la place de la paix
céleste de temps à autre c'est tung un
demi million de chinois
[Musique]
le défilé qui comporte des danseurs des
miliciens des paysans des communes
rurales des acrobates des membres des
minorités nationales des enfants
s'apparente à un long cortège de
carnaval il a duré deux heures d'horloge
avec le roi du népal la reine-mère de
belgique a assisté sans nul doute au
spectacle le plus impressionnant de
l'année
dans un hindou s'impose la technique l'
équilibre physique des travailleurs est
une nécessité premier l'alcool
représente un danger pour leur sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons demandé à monsieur texier
président de l'institut national de
sécurité si en 1961 l'alcool avait une
responsabilité importante dans les
accidents du travail
l'abus d'alcool
amenuisant les réflexes provoque un
accroissement des risques d' enquête
approfondie menée avec le concours du
corps médical il ressort que l'alcool
est responsable de 10 % des accidents
légers du travail et de 15 % des
accidents graves
il importe avant tout les travailleurs
puissent trouver sur place des voies
sont simples c'est ce but que vise plus
particulièrement les textes officiels du
mois d'août dernier fixant les
conditions dans lesquelles les boissons
non alcoolisées doivent être mises à la
disposition des travailleurs
des expériences antérieures ont prouvé
que dans les établissements où des
boissons non alcoolisées est mise à la
disposition des travailleurs
l'alcoolisme et les accidents
consécutifs et peut-être en régulation
depuis ce temps twister traduisez
tordant tarder m'étendre quoi dire et
bleu eh bien regardez
nouvelle danse à la mode le twist après
sa propre et a bien entendu envahi tous
les clubs parisiens que ce soit le club
saint germain où les nouveaux venus
comme l'amour
vient purement coeur
mais plus qu'une danse il faut voir dans
le twist un rythme et un rythme
séduisant puisqu'ils s'expriment sans
bouger les pieds on ne s'étonnera donc
pas de le voir un jour prochain envahir
notre vie
m
les cours du soir sont déjà plus
de 1 à 4 en avant et de 5 à 8 en arrière
guingamp 1 2 3 4 5
on a bien
[Musique]
m
m ainsi naît comme chez georges et rosie
toute une génération de twister
n'échappe pas qui veut aux épidémies si
nous voulons rester dans le vent il nous
faudra aussi savoir plus tu es
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]